[Musique]
j'ai quelque chose c'est fait la malle
docteur Alderwood vous avez un patient
du nom de Dylan Forester
il lui avait parlé récemment
tu n'es plus la personne que tu étais
dit là le petit frère de Dylan le
professeur John Forrester est mort on
enterre demain tu as un sacré tout bête
venir ici trouve-moi un contact à la
police de Washington
on a du mal à jouer
je pensais pas qu'ils arriveraient si
vite
vous n'êtes pas le FBI très bien observé
allez on fouille l'endroit et on se
déploie
on tue j'essaie de faire de mon mieux
ne sois pas trop dur avec toi même
je l'explorer et je vous explose tous
les deux
et maintenant tu sais ce qui se passe
quand on refuse de m'aider
on va retourner là-dedans
qu'est-ce que vous ne me dites pas
[Musique]
tu te fais canapé ouais ça fait un
moment
c'est vrai que Dylan
c'était vraiment des mauvaises personnes